PROFESSOR: So we left ourselves
at the end of the
last lecture in a somewhat
perplexing situation.
We had thought through the
particular scenarios that Judy
Thomson presents us with
in her trolley paper.
And we had discovered the
following apparently
perplexing feature about
the class's responses.
In what's called the Classic
Bystander case--
the case where there's a
bystander standing next to a
trolley that's hurtling down
a track about to hit five
people, and the bystander could
if he chose turn the
trolley onto a track where
the trolley will
only hit one person--
your responses were
as follows.
Roughly 15% of you thought he
was morally required to turn
the trolley from the
five to the one.
70% of you thought he was
morally permitted to do so.
And only 15% of you thought that
it's a morally prohibited
act for him to turn
the trolley from
the five to the one.
By contrast, we ended
class with Thomson's
famous Fat Man case.
This is a case where our
bystander is standing next to
the trolley as before, the
trolley is hurtling down the
track about to kill the five,
and the bystander has
available to him a means for
stopping the trolley.
In this case, rather than
turning it onto a different
track, the means he has
available to him is to push a
fat man off a bridge,
thereby stopping the
trolley in its tracks.
And your responses in this
case exhibited a highly
different distribution than they
did in the first case.
Whereas in the first case,
15% of you thought it was
prohibited to stop the trolley
from hitting the five by
killing the one or by causing
the trolley to kill the one,
in the Fat Man case,
78% of you--
4/5 of the class--
thought that the act of turning
or of stopping the
trolley by putting in its way
another person was morally
prohibited.
Now the puzzle that this raises,
as you know from the
end of last class, is that
it seems that in both the
Bystander case where one--
sorry.
The puzzle is this.
In the Bystander case, it seems
clear to most people
that killing one person
is bad, but that
letting five die is worse.
Whereas in the Fat Man
case, it seems
to be just the inverse.
So what Thomson asks us at the
end of that paper, having run
through a number of cases,
including some that I didn't
go over in this summary right
now, is what could possibly
explain the difference in our
reactions to the Bystander
case and the Fat Man case?
And what she suggests is that
whereas utility prohibits
letting the five die--
that is, it would be better for
the number of lives saved
if we saved five than
if we saved one--
the notion of a right is what
prohibits killing the one in
the Fat Man case.
So what has to happen, says
Thomson in the Fat Man case,
is that you interfere with his
right not to have his person
used as a means to the end
of saving another.
Whereas in the case of
Bystander, there's no right
that is infringed upon.
And, suggests Thomson, rights
trump utilities.
So what the right prohibits
is what is mandated
in the Fat Man case.
So that's where we were at the
end of class last time.
And the solution that Thomson
proposed there is what we
might call a classic solution
to trolley-type dilemmas.
It's a solution that assumes
that Fat Man case and the
Bystander case carry different
moral mandates, and that the
reason they carry those
different mandates is because
of a deep moral difference
that those cases encode.
So the difference between our
response to Fat Man and our
response to Bystander, says
Thomson in that 1985 article,
is one that we should respect.
And the reason we should respect
that difference, she
contends, is that that
difference is tracking a
profound moral difference
between them, namely that in
the case of Fat Man but not in
the case of Bystander, the
rights of an individual
are violated.
What I want to do in class today
is to go through with
you three non-classic responses
to the trolley case.
And I'll be giving you the
chance to use your clickers in
the first and third of these.
So if you get your clickers
out, we'll be prepared for
what's going to happen
in a few minutes.
So what are the three
classic responses?
Remember, in a classic response,
the claim is that
Fat Man and Bystander carry
different moral mandates, and
that that difference can be
traced to a deeper, morally
relevant difference
between them.
So two of the responses that
we'll consider today are ones
that suggest that Fat Man and
Bystander in fact don't carry
different moral mandates.
So the first example that I'm
going to run through with you
is Judy Thomson's rethinking
of trolley cases in a 2008
paper in which she ends up
assimilating the Bystander
case to the Fat Man case.
And suggesting that in neither
of the cases is it permissible
to kill the one to
save the five.
The second view that we'll
consider is Josh Greene's view
that the right thing to do in
the Fat Man case is the same
thing as the right thing to do
in the Bystander case, namely
that in both cases, the right
thing to do is to stop the
trolley from hitting the
five and cause it
instead to kill the one.
And finally--
I'm shoe-horning this a bit,
because in truth, Sunstein is
a little closer to Greene
than he is to Thomson.
But we might use his thinking to
maintain the position that
though our responses to the
cases differ, the cases are in
some more fundamental
sense the same.
And what Sunstein is going to
suggest we need to do is to
push the fat man.
So what we have are
three views here.
Thomson's saying the cases come
together, and they come
together in telling us
never to kill the
one to save the five.
Greene's saying the cases come
together, and they come
together in telling us always
kill the one to save the five.
And then, perhaps, Sunstein's
view telling us that the cases
come apart.
But these three non-classic
responses are interesting not
just for the difference in their
content, I think they're
interesting for the purposes of
this class because each of
them makes use of a slightly
different kind of
argumentative methodology.
And there's no reason that the
methodologies and the answers
needed to line up in the
way that they did.
So one of the things that I want
you to think about as we
go through today's lecture is
what use might be made of each
of these methodologies
to make one of
the alternative arguments.
So Thomson's contention that
in the Bystander case we
shouldn't turn the trolley is
one that she makes on the
basis of inviting you--
as I will do in a moment--
to consider additional
hypothetical cases, and then
asking you to be consistent
about your responses to cases
that fail to differ
in moral ways.
So Thomson's methodology is the
same as it was in her 1985
paper, there's just a new case
that she's thought about.
Sunstein's methodology is to
canvas a large array of
literature in the heuristics and
biases tradition, and to
suggest that moral reasoning is
no different than any other
sort of reasoning.
And Josh Greene's method is
of course to make use of
neuroimaging results and on that
basis to argue in favor
of his view that what is morally
mandated of us is a
certain kind of utilitarian
stance.
So let's start--
and here you'll need
your clickers--
with the additional hypothetical
cases that
convinced Judy Thomson, and may
convince you, that it's
not OK to turn the trolley
in Bystander.
So the case that Thomson
presents us with is a case
that we'll call Bystander's
Three Options.
So here's poor Jim, deeply
regretting that he ever
enrolled in this class, standing
by the trolley in a
usual Bystander dilemma where
the trolley is about to hit
the five and Jim has the
possibility of deflecting it
to hit the one.
But because Jim lives his life
in Judy Thomson's thought
experiment, she has, in rather
dastardly fashion, introduced
a third track at the end of
which, rather unfortunately
for Jim, Jim is standing.
Now here's Jim's three-way
dilemma.
One, allow the trolley to
continue on its original path
killing the five.
Option two, deflect the
trolley so that it
hits the other guy.
Option three, deflect
the trolley from
the five to the one--
oh, except the one is Jim.
Question.
In three-way Bystander, if Jim
decides to turn the trolley--
so we're ignoring the
case where he
lets it hit the five--
he's made the decision to turn
the trolley, the question is
the following.
Is it morally required for him
to turn the trolley onto the
track where it hits the other
guy instead of himself?
Is it morally permitted, but not
morally required, for him
to turn the trolley onto the
track where it hits the other
guy instead of himself?
Or is it morally prohibited for
him to turn the trolley
onto the track instead
of to himself?
So we're assuming that Jim has
made the decision to turn the
trolley from the five.
After all, it's a straight
Bystander case.
If he doesn't turn
the trolley, it's
going to hit the five.
78% of you have previously told
me that what one ought to
do, or at least what one is
permitted to do in this case,
is to turn the trolley.
How come there's no responses
coming, guys?
STUDENTS: [INTERPOSING VOICES].
PROFESSOR: It's not working?
Oh, my goodness.
All right.
So why is it not open for you?
Let's try.
Is it open now?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR: Tragic.
This is really, really,
very, very horrible.
That did not work.
OK, the whole lecture today
depends upon these working.
So let's try this again.
And tell me now whether
this works.
Is it working?
OK.
Is it working now?
No?
Still no?
All right.
Hm.
We're going to have to run--
I think there's nothing
I can do.
I'm going to try resetting
once more
and see if that works.
And I'm going to try
removing and then
returning this receiver.
And then--
if not-- we're going to do the
old-fashioned show of hands
and all my beautifully
constructed slides will turn
out not to be useful, but
that's all right.
Worse things have happened
in the world.
All right.
Try it again.
Yay!
Awesome.
I have no idea what I changed.
OK.
So, answering this question.
Wow.
There's 64 of you.
There's 71 of you.
We'll do the countdown.
10, 9, 8--
so let's see how the numbers
come out in--
4, 3, 2, 1 seconds.
Oh, and it's so exciting.
Especially because we
had to suffer first.
The contrast. OK.
So in this case, 6% of you think
it's morally required
for Jim to turn the trolley
onto the other man.
But you were the 6% who continue
to be outliers, or
perhaps you're different
people.
But let's look at
what's going on.
61% of you think it's morally
permitted for him to turn the
trolley onto the other man.
And 32% of you think it's
morally prohibited for him to
turn the trolley onto
the other man.
Now interestingly, Judy Thomson
expects that more of
you will fall into
this category.
So it's an interesting question
for us to think about
as a class why it is that she
is under the impression that
it's rather surprising that this
is the response that you
gave. But in any case, let's
move to a second contrast case
and see how this goes.
OK.
Suppose now that we have
only a two-way case.
In the two-way case, bystander
Jim has only two options.
Either the trolley is going to
hit the five or he can deflect
the trolley in such a way
that it hits him.
I want to go back for a second
and just get the numbers that
I got on the last slide, because
I forgot to record
those for myself, thrown off
as I was by our situation.
So let me just record these.
6%, 61%, 32%.
OK.
So moving on to the new case.
It's a two-way trolley, and
the question is this.
In Bystander's Two Options, is
it morally required for him to
let the trolley hit the five
instead of himself, is it
morally permitted for him to let
the trolley hit the five
instead of himself, or is it
morally prohibited for him to
let the trolley hit the five
instead of himself?
OK?
So let's think through
that case.
So remember, it's
a two-way case.
The trolley's heading down
towards the five.
And the question is: is it
required, permitted, or
prohibited for him to turn
the trolley from
the five to hit himself?
OK.
And let's see how the numbers
come out here.
We've got roughly 10 seconds
to find out whether your
distribution is going to be
similar or different here.
OK, so here's how the numbers
come out: 8%, 70%, 22%.
Now, the case with which we want
to contrast this is the
classic Bystander case.
In the classic Bystander case,
more of you thought he was
morally required to turn the
trolley than you think in this
particular case.
In the classic Bystander case,
interestingly, you had roughly
the same view about whether
it was morally permitted.
And more of you think it's
morally prohibited for him to
let the trolley hit the five
instead of himself.
So the interesting difference
is this one here.
You took a different attitude
with respect to whether it's
morally required for him to
turn the trolley when the
person it's going to hit is
himself than when the person
it's going to hit is
another person.
So let's go back and do just a
classic Bystander case and see
whether, as a result of having
thought through this case, if
there's any change in
your intuitions.
So this is just the standard
Bystander case that you've
seen before.
In the classic two-way Bystander
case, do you think
it's morally mandatory, morally
permitted, or morally
prohibited for Jim to
turn the trolley?
So we're 3, 2, 1.
And let's see how the
numbers come out.
20%, 65%, 15%.
So as a result of having thought
about the first-person
analogue, some--
though many fewer than I
would have thought--
some of you changed your view.
Whereas originally, 15% of you
thought it was morally
mandatory to turn
the trolley--
oh, you've changed your view
exactly the direction against
the one I would have
predicted.
So here's a mystery.
Here's a little bit of
experimental philosophy done
in our classroom.
What Judy Thomson was
predicting-- and we can talk
in sections about why this
didn't happen --
what Judy Thomson was predicting
is that you would
react as follows.
If it's not morally mandatory
for me to turn the trolley
onto myself, then it's not
morally mandatory, indeed not
morally permitted, for me
to turn the trolley
onto another person.
If I'm not willing to take a
hit myself in that case, I
shouldn't be deciding on behalf
of another person that
he take that hit.
So I want you to think about
what it is in Thomson's
thinking about this case that
made it feel to her so obvious
that as the result of
considering the first-person
case, people would be inclined
to rethink the
third-person case.
And I have to say, I myself in
reading Thomson's 2008 paper
am very easily brought
into the mindset
she describes there.
So I find it surprising and
extremely interesting to see
that that isn't what happened
in this context.
Let's assume, however, that at
least for some of you, the
intuition that you came to
have as the result of
considering this case
was something
like Thomson's intuition.
So that whereas on the old view
in Bystander case, you
thought the right thing was to
kill the one rather than to
let the five die-- that is, in
the standard switch case, and
this is in fact what most of
you think-- in the standard
Bystander case, most of you
think that the right thing to
do is to kill the one rather
than to let the five die.
What Thomson says is that
in thinking through the
first-person case, you ought to
realize that Bystander is a
lot more like Fat Man than
you initially thought.
To the extent that you reject
that intuition of Thomson's,
you're in a position to
disagree with her.
So let's move to the view with
which I take it most of you
are going to end up agreeing,
since this is exactly the
opposite of Thomson's, namely
Greene's argument that the
assimilation ought to
go the other way.
So just to remind you where we
are in the picture, the puzzle
with which we began is that
people were giving a different
response in Bystander than in
Fat Man, and Thomson tried to
get rid of the problem by
causing you to assimilate
Bystander to Fat Man.
I was unable through Thomson's
cases to get you to shift your
intuitions in that case.
So we're stuck with a
residual difference
between your responses.
Most of you think it's OK to
turn the trolley in Bystander
regardless of whether you
wouldn't do it on yourself,
but that it's not OK to
push the man on the
bridge in Fat Man.
So Greene's going to give us a
second way of thinking about
how it is that we might bring
those responses together.
And his argument runs
as follows.
In general, we're not in
a very good position to
determine what really underlies
our reasoning.
There's an entire tradition in
social psychology that I
talked about in one of the early
lectures that aims to
show that a lot of what people
engage in when they make
decisions is post-facto
rationalization of intuitive
responses that they had which
weren't in fact tracking what
they would say are the relevant
features of the situation.
So famously, people are more
likely to choose an object
that lies on the left-hand side
of a visual array than an
object that lies on the
right-hand side
of that visual array.
But in making the choice, they
don't provide as their reason
the location of the object, they
provide as their reason
some other feature
of the object.
And when we looked at, in
the second lecture, the
confabulation results, whereby
subjects who had undergone
commissurotomy--
that is, whose corpus callosum
had been severed--
so that the right and left
hemispheres of their brains
weren't in communication, we
discovered that when they
performed an act that was based
on stimulation of the
right brain, the left brain,
which is the linguistic part,
came up with an explanation for
what they were doing that
was obviously not the real
source of their behavior.
So there are many cases, Greene
points out, where our
motivations our opaque us.
Where we think we're responding
to one thing, but
in fact we're responding
to something else.
One of those cases, says Greene,
is the difference in
our response to the Fat
Man case and to
the Bystander case.
So what happens in the
Bystander case--
where we're trying to decide
whether to shift the trolley
from the five to the one--
is that our rational
processing system gets activated.
Whereas what happens,
hypothesizes Greene-- and
we'll give some evidence in a
minute-- what happens in the
Fat Man case is that our
emotional processing system
gets activated.
And says Greene, given the
choice between our rational
system and our emotional system,
the rational system is
the one whose outputs we ought
to trust. So says Greene, the
morally right thing to
do in this case is to
push the fat man.
Notice that this is a multi-step
argument, some of
whose premises are
a good deal more
controversial than others.
So the premise that our
motivations are often opaque
to us is completely undisputed
by everyone.
There's no question that often
we aren't aware of what's
causing us to respond
in a particular way.
I may be particularly irritable
because my feet are
wet, and unaware of the fact
that the reason that I'm
responding to you in a
short-tempered way is not
because you are particularly
irritating, but because my
feet are uncomfortable.
This phenomenon is undeniable.
The question of whether what
actually explains our
different responses in these
two cases is an interesting
empirical question.
And there has been collected
over the last decade or so
some pretty interesting
neuroimaging data suggesting
that there are systematic
activation differences in what
goes on when people give
utilitarian responses to cases
and what goes on when people
give responses to cases that
seem to involve the sorts
of notions to which
deontologists appeal.
Notions like rights.
And there is a certain amount of
additional evidence coming
from other research that the
areas that are differentially
activated in those two cases
correspond on the one hand
with what is often thought of
as a rational processing
system-- a calculative
processing system--
whereas in the other, they
correspond with areas of the
brain that have been in
independent cases implicated
in emotional processing.
So the first premise
is uncontroversial.
The second premise is reasonably
well-supported.
There's controversy about the
data, but there is scientific
evidence for which there's a
good argument to be made that
what it shows is roughly
what's written here.
The controversial question is
whether even if the first two
premises are true, the third
normative premise is true.
Is it the case that if our
responses to Fat Man are
triggered by emotion, whereas
our responses to Bystander are
triggered by the rational
system, is it the case that we
ought to go with the
rational system?
That is a normative claim,
not an empirical one.
And even if the arguments that
we're going to consider in a
minute successfully establish
the truth of the second
premise, we don't yet have the
truth of the third premise
thereby established.
So let's talk about evidence
that Greene has found in favor
of the premise that what goes on
in cases like Fat Man is an
emotional response, whereas
what goes on in cases like
classic Bystander is a
rational response.
So Greene has for the last
decade or so put people into
fMRI machines-- into scanners
which track where blood is
flowing in the brain--
and presented them in
the scanners with
three kinds of dilemmas.
The first kind of dilemma are
dilemmas that he calls
moral/personal dilemmas.
These are dilemmas like Fat Man
where you're being asked
whether you want to push the
fat man off the bridge.
Dilemmas like the doctor case,
which I presented, where we're
considering whether to cut up a
healthy patient to save the
lives of others.
Dilemmas like a lifeboat case
where there's not enough food
and water to go around on
the lifeboat and you're
considering whether to throw off
one of the people on the
lifeboat so as to leave enough
food and water to go around
for the remaining subjects.
So that's the first class of
cases that he has subjects
consider in the scanner.
The second class of cases that
he has people consider in the
scanner are what he calls moral
and impersonal cases.
So these are cases like
Bystander at the switch where
you're facing a moral dilemma,
but not one where you are
imagining, in an up-close and
personal way, causing
particular harm to a particular
individual who's in
your proximity.
Cases like ones where you've
found a lost wallet and you
need to decide whether
to return it.
Cases where you're voting on a
policy that will have certain
kinds of effects on people, but
where those effects are
relatively remote from you.
And finally, he presents people
with what he calls
non-moral dilemmas.
Questions like, if I'm trying
to get from Cleveland to
Chicago, should I take the bus
or the train or a plane?
Or if I'm trying to decide which
coupon to use on the
internet to save on shipping,
should I do this or that?
Cases that involve the same
kinds of objects, right?
Fat Man involves trains.
Bus versus train involves
trains.
We might have a coupon-use case
where you're using the
coupon to buy a boat.
Lifeboat involves a boat.
So he has the subjects in the
scanner and they're presented
with these sorts of cases.
And you'll notice that I've put
a little color-coded box
here of black, grey,
and white.
What Greene discovered
in the 2001 paper--
and let me say some of these
data have since been
re-analyzed, so some of the
details haven't held up, but
many of them have--
what he discovered is that if
one believes, as many do, that
the brain areas listed here--
brain areas like medial frontal
gyrus, and angular
gyrus, and posterior
cingulate gyrus--
if one believes that those are
areas associated with emotion,
then we have good evidence that
in the moral/personal
cases, the areas of the
brain associated
with emotion are activated.
Whereas in the moral/impersonal
and non-moral
cases that doesn't occur.
By contrast, it looks like
a bunch of areas that are
traditionally associated
with working memory--
parietal lobe, middle
frontal gyrus--
are more active in the
impersonal case and the
non-moral case than they are
in the personal case.
And here's the famous image
from Greene's 2001 paper
reproduced in many papers since
that shows the brain
areas that exhibit differential
response in the
moral/personal cases
as contrasted
with the other cases.
So it looks like there is
some, perhaps decisive,
evidence in favor of Greene's
second premise.
In favor of the premise that
what goes on in moral/personal
cases is an activation of the
part of the brain associated
with emotion, whereas what
goes on in cases like
Bystander is an activation
of the part of the brain
associated with reasoning
and other sorts of
more-controlled processes.
Moreover says Greene, there's
lots and lots of behavioral
evidence that supports the
hypothesis that one of the
things that goes on when we
respond to hypothetical moral
dilemmas is that we track
features of the case that are
not morally relevant.
So for example, there's a study
from the early 2000s by
behavioral economists Small and
Loewenstein that points
out that in a very profound
sense, identifiable victims
produce in us more powerful
emotional responses the
non-identifiable victims. And
this isn't just the difference
between a picture of the child
to whom your Oxfam donations
will go versus a description
of the child to whom your
Oxfam donations will go.
There is in fact a strikingly
large difference between
people's willingness to give
some of their rewards in a
game in a laboratory to
person number four--
right, so they draw a name from
a hat and it says person
number four--
than in cases where they're
told, decide how much money
you want to give to the person
whose number you're about to
draw from the hat.
In neither of these instances do
they know who person number
four is going to be.
But the fact that in the first
case, the person they draw
from the hat and it says person
number four, and they
think, oh, I'll give
this amount of my
proceeds to the person.
Whereas in the second case,
they decide what amount of
proceeds they want to give to
the person whose number they
are about to draw.
The fact that that produces
in subjects consistently
different responses suggests
to Greene, and perhaps to
others of you, that perhaps
using our intuitions about
these sorts of cases to build
our moral theories may not be
the best way to proceed, since
presumably there are few of
you who think that there is a
relevant moral difference
between whether you know the
number of the person to whom
you're going to be giving the
gift or whether you're about
to find out the number of the
person to whom you're going to
be giving the gift.
Here's something else that
appears to affect our moral
responses to cases.
This is work done by Jon Haidt,
author of The Happiness
Hypothesis, with various
collaborators.
If you're deciding how much
punishment to give somebody--
if you're deciding how
wrong an act was--
if you have been induced to
feel disgust, either by
sitting at a dirty table or
by having been trained to
associate certain terms with
disgust through a hypnotic
suggestion, you will be harsher
in punishing people
for their misdeeds.
Now, I take it that most of you
don't think people deserve
harsher punishment when you are
feeling disgust because
the table in front
of you is dirty.
I take it you think that how
bad an act is that somebody
else has done is independent of
your feelings of disgust.
But it looks like one of the
things that condemnation
tracks is that feeling.
And in a minute, I'll talk about
how that connects to
Sunstein's more general
discussion of heuristics.
Finally, some work by David
Pizarro, a Yale PhD, suggest
that in specific trolley cases,
we can get people's
intuitions to move around in
cases like Fat Man just by
varying what most people would
say are morally irrelevant
features of the situation.
In particular, Pizarro presents
subjects with two
different versions of
the Fat Man case.
In the first, you're asked
whether it is morally
permitted, required, or
prohibited, to push a man
named Tyrone Peyton off the
bridge in order to save 100
members of the New York
Philharmonic.
And in the second, you're asked
whether it's morally
acceptable to push a man named
Chip Ellsworth III off the
bridge to save 100 members of
the Harlem Jazz Orchestra.
So the question is whether
pushing a white man off the
bridge to save 100 people of
African descent or pushing a
black man off the bridge to save
100 people of European
descent should produce
different responses.
And interestingly--
perhaps as the result
of a certain kind of
self-correction--
liberals say it is less morally
acceptable to push
Tyrone Peyton off the
bridge than to
produce Chip Ellsworth.
Regardless of which direction
the numbers come out, what's
interesting is the numbers come
out differently, tracking
a feature which most of us would
think isn't a morally
relevant feature.
So it looks like strengthening
Greene's second premise-- and
this is an argument that he
makes in more detail in a
paper, from which we'll read
excerpts after the break,
called "The Secret Joke of
Kant's Soul"-- it looks like
there's pretty good reason to
think at least some of our
responses to these cases are
tracking features which we
wouldn't reflectively endorse.
And Greene thinks in particular
in Fat Man, our
reluctance to push the fat man
off the bridge is tracking one
of those morally irrelevant
features.
Deontological judgments, says
Greene-- those where we're
unwilling to make the
utilitarian move--
deontological judgments, says
Greene, are driven by
emotional responses.
Consequentialist judgments are
driven by cognitive ones.
And the deontological responses,
he says, lack moral
significance.
In fact, deontology itself is a
kind of moral confabulation.
I'm going to give Kant the last
word in this lecture.
So those of you who are crying
for the sage of Konigsberg,
realize that he will get the
very last word in today's
lecture complete with a
beautiful image of his face.
But before I do that I want to
spend the final 10 substantive
minutes of the lecture talking
you through the third article
which we are considering
for today, namely
Cass Sunstein's article.
So Sunstein, in somewhat similar
vein to Greene, though
drawing on a slightly different
literature, argues
that a good portion of our moral
reasoning operates in
exactly the same way that our
regular reasoning does, namely
by making use of heuristics,
which we know about from the
lecture on January 20
on dual processing.
Heuristics are fast and frugal
tools for dealing with the
complexity of the world
when we're faced with
time-sensitive, decision-making
tasks.
And the way that heuristics
work is really smart.
They work by means of something
called attribute
substitution.
We're interested in a
target attribute--
something that's relatively
hard to find
out about the world.
And we focus our attention
instead on a heuristic
attribute--
something that's relatively
easy to find
out about the world.
So some of you may make use of
this when you're trying to
distinguish your telephone
from other people's
telephones.
The target attribute--
the thing you're really
interested in is--
is this my phone?
Something which you're only
going to be able to determine
by turning on the phone and
looking to see whether the
numbers in it are the numbers
that you've placed
into it, let's say.
But you might make your life
easy by putting a cover on
your phone or a sticker on your
phone or some surface
feature on your phone that will
let you find your phone
quickly and well.
Right?
So you're going to make use of
an easy to find attribute
rather than a difficult to
determine attribute.
In general, this is an
extraordinarily good way to
navigate the world.
Target and heuristic attributes
generally coincide.
That's how the heuristic
attributes came to be the ones
which you're using as the
markers of the target.
And it takes much less effort to
process surface features of
the world than to spend your
time working through the
details of each of the
things that you want
to make sense of.
So I observed myself this
morning making use of a target
attribute on my way
into school.
I was stopped at a stoplight,
and I noticed out of the
corner of my eye that
the car next to me
had started to move.
Now obviously, the attribute in
which I was interested in
was whether the light
had turned green.
But because I couldn't quite see
the green light from where
I was sitting, I was able to use
instead the motion of the
car next to me as an indicator
of the thing that I was
concerned with.
Now of course, the heuristic
could have
misfired in this case.
It could have been that that car
was moving even though the
light was still red.
It could have been that that
car was moving in the left
lane and had a special
light that I didn't.
But for the most part, we make
use of heuristics all the time
and they help us.
Now Sunstein's argument is
that in non-moral cases,
people often use heuristics.
That though these are useful,
they may also lead to errors.
And that in moral cases,
people often use
heuristics as well.
But just as they may lead to
errors in the non-moral cases,
so too may they lead to errors
in the moral cases.
And in particular, he thinks
they do in a number of cases
that he goes on to discuss.
And I realize, I think we're
going to close--
I said Kant would get the last
word, but Kant's going to get
the last word on Thursday.
We're going to go through
Sunstein and one of the
examples, and then we'll
get to Kant.
So Sunstein points out, for
example, that there's a
heuristic called the
availability heuristic.
That's a heuristic that says,
look, I'm trying to figure out
how likely something is to
happen, and here's a good way
to determine how likely
something is to happen.
I think about how easy it is for
me to think of cases where
that did happen.
So whenever I'm worried that
my children are going to be
kidnapped, I think for myself,
how many friends do I know
whose children were kidnapped?
How many people do I know whose
children were kidnapped?
And when I discover that the
answer is none, I relax.
This kind of heuristic
is often correct, but
it can lead us astray.
Suppose, for example, you're
asked whether it's more likely
whether there are more words in
the English language that
end in I-N-G or more words in
the English language whose
second-to-last letter is N. It's
much easier to think of
words that end with I-N-G, and
so people tend to say that
there are more words ending
in I-N-G than words whose
second-to-last letter is N. But
of course, every word that
ends with I-N-G is a word whose
second-to-last letter is
N. You've been bamboozled by
the availability heuristic.
Or suppose you make use of
what's sometimes called the
representative heuristic.
That the probability of
something occurring tracks its
degree of typicality.
This too is often correct.
What it is to be a typical
instance is to be one of the
instances that occurs
more frequently.
But as you know from the Linda
the bank teller case or the
farmer with a tractor case,
if I ask you of our random
resident of Iowa whether it's
more likely that that resident
is a farmer or a farmer with a
tractor, the representative
heuristic is going to draw you
towards saying that it's more
likely that the person is
a farmer with a tractor.
But obviously, every
farmer with a
tractor is also a farmer.
Now remember that Sunstein's
arguments for one and two are
easy to make because we have
an independent way of
determining whether somebody
has made an
error in those cases.
We can see what went wrong in
the availability heuristic and
in the representative heuristic,
because we can see
that it is in fact more likely
that the second-to-last letter
of a word is N than it is that
the last three letters of the
word are I-N-G. We can see that
it's more likely that
somebody's a farmer than
it is that somebody's a
farmer with a tractor.
Because in both of those
cases, one of them is a
special instance of the other.
Sunstein's argument for moral
heuristics is going to take
more steps.
Because it's not enough for
him to show what we'll
establish--
that in moral cases, people
often use heuristics--
he's also going to need to show
that in so doing, they're
making mistakes.
Where the question of how we get
an independent handle on
what it is to make a mistake is
a rather complicated one.
But let's first think about what
his argument in favor of
the claim that in moral
cases people often
use heuristics is.
And I'm going to close today's
lecture with two
examples that he gives.
And then we'll begin on Thursday
by running through
some particular cases where
I'll ask you to respond.
So one of the examples that he
provides is again some work by
Jonathan Haidt on a phenomenon
known as moral dumbfounding.
As you know from reading
Sunstein's paper, people often
respond to the question: "Is
it morally acceptable for a
brother and sister to engage
in consensual, harm-free
sibling incestuous relations?"
by saying that it is morally
unacceptable.
But when asked to provide
reasons for that, subjects
find it difficult to do so.
Likewise, many people are
inclined to think there's
something morally problematic
about wiping the floor of your
bathroom with a flag, or about
eating your dog if he's been
hit by a car, but they find it
difficult to articulate what
their reasons are for
those responses.
Sunstein suggests the reason
is an overextension of
heuristics.
Likewise, he points out in
moral framing cases-- and
we'll start with this
next lecture--
cases like the Asian disease
case that I presented you with
in our lecture on January 20,
whether you present a moral
dilemma as involving
lives saved, or by
contrast lives lost--
even when those are just
complementary descriptions of
the same outcome--
people are likely to have
different responses.
And Sunstein concludes on that
basis that people make use of
heuristics in moral reasoning
just as they do
in non-moral reasoning.
And we'll begin on Thursday with
Sunstein's discussion of
those cases, and then we'll let
Kant and Mill get the last
words in the trolley debate.
I'll see you then.